all
right uh let's just work with
katata so he's going to grab cool all
right we do it again watch his grip
cool and one more
time cool all right uh let's do this
side now so you can see on the back side
cool a little
slower slow cool and again
all
right A lot of times what we do
is uh we might recognize his spinal
displacement so you're going to see I
won't ground it this time as he goes you
could see it in the tilt of his torso
okay do it one more time I won't ground
it so you see the effect on me
okay um and so we P we think he's going
this way and so as long as
I um have my motion going in a in a
harmonious Direction with that we think
we have not
contested okay but if we just slow
motion uh pretend my arm is
there okay and if you pay attention the
fingers are going the other way so yes
his spine he's doing spinal displacement
but the fingers are going back the other
way do you see that so if I actually go
this way I'm actually contesting the
fingers
okay your choreograph ID they were going
to fly that way anyway so you don't
really feel it but your scaredy cat ukes
or the ukes who are just grounding
you'll feel the fingers okay and and
you'll feel the Yong of the fingers
because you're yanging on the fingers
okay um that is another reason why the
hand workk that we use isn't for example
like this
one here remember remember that EO
because you're pulling against the
fingers that's a y Yong Clash even
though it's not a push push it's a pull
p pull
okay a lot of people that do that
version like to have that
pull that they're looking for that it's
the same o uh you know ego tripartite
mind will to power overpowering okay but
it's not iido it's this young young
Clash okay but in our handworth you'll
see that the tabaki that we use it's
going to reconcile the fingerpull as as
it reconciles the spinal displacement so
for example in
Gon Do you see his fingers are going
this way and I'm turning within his
fingers and as I do gon you see that my
hand can come back towards me without
losing the elbow angle meaning I don't
have to go like this do you see so in my
gon
I don't pull on the fingers I'm inside
his grip got it and so the the Eco that
we're doing is I go this way do you see
and then around and I'm working inside
the fingers on the inward
fire
so I never feel his fingers do that
again remember his fingers are doing
that I don't I go around his fingers
around his fingers inside his
palm okay some of the stuff we were
doing like if I if I come here and I go
to Cheon remember his fingers are still
going that way right and go to chew on I
don't feel his fingers till the grip
weakens and then I'm
[Music]
out so again and in fingers are still
curling that way then I'm inside his
grip not inside his
fingers till they
weaken meaning they become Yin and I can
push through
them same thing I go to
jodon I'm
inside I'm not going to pull on his
fingers his fingers are going going that
way not going to pull on his finger and
try to get up as I'm going through I'm
I'm in
here in here never feeling his
g bo
pop inside his STP inside his grip
inside no don't pull push inside his
and there it
[Music]
is inside the grip inside the grip
inside the grip never against the
fingers okay uh so that will be our
first progression those are the three
techniques we did in the last video on
tesak okay and you take that first one
into EO we went to Koko we'll take it
into EO okay and then you had ID nag in
Chan and then we had hij at
J TR